et bien aujourd'hui j'ai envie de vous
parler de la respiration en courant
parce que très souvent on me dira ah là
là j'arrive pas à respirer c'est pour ça
je fais pas de course à pied je fais pas
de sport j'ai jamais su respirer bon
c'est pas très dur faut savoir qu'en
courant évidemment on peut pas respirer
comme quand on marche dans la rue ça me
paraît évident donc il faut essayer de
calquer votre respiration je vais
l'exagérer pour vous montrer sur vos
foulée et vous partez sur un rythme de 3
3 3 inspiration 3 expiration ça va faire
ça c'est bon vous avez compris
bon après s'il ya une côte où si le
rythme s'accélère vous pouvez passer sur
du 2 2 parce que vous avez besoin de
plus d'oxygène donc ça va faire bon pour
l'instant on n'en est pas là on va
rester sur le 3-3 que vous calqué sur
vos pas ça va faire ça et donc au départ
forcé vous il pensait concentrez-vous là
dessus après ça va devenir machinal une
chose est sûre c'est que très rapidement
vous ne pensez même plus à votre
respiration pendant que vous courrez ça
sera naturel magique que à bientôt pour
de nouveaux conseils